有と無の問題点 はい それで今日は私は言ってないんだけど
有は極論なんです 無も極論なんです
人は有に執着するか 無に執着するかなんです
つまり 今日私の説明は経典ではそれで終わりますけど
お釈迦様は人は有に執着するか
無に執着するかと 両方苦痛だよと
もう随分簡単に終わってますけど
簡単じゃないんで 私は言うのは
無もろくな無ではありませんと
あれは単純に有のマイナスだけであると
問題点がありますよ 現象は有と取ると
まずその人は無知ですね
物事はあると言ったら無知に決まってる
なぜならば 賞の3分の1知らない
熱の3分の1知らない 3
分の2を知らないで 3
分の1だけ知って偉そうな見栄張っちゃうと
もう無知でしょう だから
思うと無の間で行ったり来たりする人々は基本的に無知なんです
現象に対して執着か嫌悪
怒りなどが生まれる あると思ってもないと思っても
執着 嫌悪 嫌な気持ち 怒り
落ち込みなどなどの煩悩が必ず生まれるんです
ですから 心は汚れます
有としても無としても心は汚れるんです
有は常に有であって 無にはならないのです
これがわからない文章なんですけど
これしか簡単に書ける方法はないんです
ということは  我々の心はいつでも有有有とあるあるあるあるだけだからね
頭の中でしっかりと実体論
実存論というかね 我はありきと
具体的に我はいるという
そこをずっと続くんです
この束縛が ですから 悪人は本質的に悪人で変わらないんです
たとえ話で言えば だからあるんだから変化しないでしょうに
だから皆様も人が何か悪いことをしたら
それからもう断言的にあいつは悪人だともう決めちゃうんです
しかし 人がいいことをしても
あの人は良い人やって
なんで断言的に決めないんですかね
性格見えるでしょ 誰かが万引きでもなんとか強盗でもしたら
もう危ない人だ 悪人だ
強盗だ 信頼できないんだと言って
その人には終身的な判決を下す
有の世界なんです 変わりませんよと
しかし そういう我々は
人が良いことをしても
あ あの人はとてもいい人やと終身的に判断はしませんね
その時一個だけ あ あれはまあいいことをやりましたね
あの人はと したがって
その人は良い人間だというところにいかないでしょ
それで皆様の性格は何ですかね
いかに気持ち悪い性格かというと
他人を差別する 侮辱する
否定する 貶す 自分を持ち上げる
この上ないようなものにする
こういう煩悩は人間にあるんだよと
だから今日の中道の話っていうのは
ものの見事に人間の姿を世に現す教えですから
これは極限に難しいんです
どうしようもないんです
我々は有論者です 実体論者です
だから人が悪いことしちゃうと
実体論に乗ってしまったて
あの人は悪人に決まっていると
人が良いことをすると
あの人は善人に決まっていると言わないんですね
だからだらしない実体論者なんですね
実体論者でありながら
性格は最低悪いんです
実体論者たちの中でも性格が良い方じゃないんです
私は読んでいる本の中でも
人間が本来本当に善人だよと言っているのはないんです
一回いいことをしたんだから
この人はそれで十両やと
結構やという教えがないんです
しかし 罪を犯したらお前終わりや
いとも簡単に言う まあほとんどの相手に至っても
例えば仏教の世界では
大乗仏教の世界でもね
やっぱり本覚思想やらね
本来みんなもう悟っているんだとかね
みんなに仏性があるんだとかは
慈しみの思考はありますよ
平等の思考 それは仏教の世界なんです
仏教の世界で性格のいい哲学は言ってますけどね
生命はみんな本来悟ってますよと
あれ 何学というんですか？なんとか学でね
本学ですね あれは本学
気学と言った方がすでに悟っているというよね
一点性格は良さそうに見えるでしょ
もう確かに性格は良さそうなんですが
実体論者なんです うろんにうろんにしがみしいているんだから
お釈迦様は極限論者だと
したがって邪見だと捨てられているんです
捨てられていても ブッダにはね
性格は悪い方じゃないんです
それも仏教だけなんですよ
世界の教えではそれはないんです
性格が悪いんです 邪見でありながら性格も悪い
仏教の教えではね もう大乗仏教のね
各宗派の教えでは邪見ですが
性格は悪いとは言えないんです
悪い人間ではないんです
頭だけです 悪いのは 性格はよろしいんです
道徳 倫理 意思で行う行為によって状況は変わるはずはないんです
で すべてをだったらもう変わらないでしょうに
だから道徳は成り立たないんです
あるあるあるだけになっちゃうと
私は頑張ってこのあることを変えましょうとはありえないんです
だから うろん者はには道徳成り立たないんです
努力成り立たないんです
意志は成り立たないんです
で 絶対的な神がいて 永遠不滅の魂があるんだと言って
その上道徳まで語るのはいい加減なんです
だから一神教の道徳っていうのはいつでもガタガタガタガタで
例えばカトリック教会は
教会の聖職者たちは結婚してはならないと言いつつも
一部の人々はもうもう反乱を起こしているんです
結婚を許せなさいと   聖職者にも
そこであの狂暴な教皇も
あのすでに結婚している人が聖職者になったら
まあ結婚 既婚者のあれは許しますとかね
いい加減 だから性行為はどうですかね
それだったら 一部の神父さんが性交してもよろしいし
一部の神父さんにはとんでもないことよ
何言ってるんですかね
道徳そのものを欠いた方でしょうね
一部の人殺しは否定するんですけど
一部の人殺しは肯定する
昔のカトリック教会は堂々と死刑までするんですね
人の まあそういうことだから
有論では道徳成り立たないんです
そんな頑張ってて変わるわけないでしょうとかね
ということになっちゃうんです
そういうことでたくさん問題があるんです
したがって 道徳倫理は倫理成り立たない
救いはないんです 有だけ取っちゃうと
無の思考は存在を否定する傾向です
逆に無っていうのは ただ存在を否定する
人があるとするものはないというだけで
無を認識しているわけではないんです
じゃあ有から無に飛んでみましょう
無に飛んでみても あるものはないと言っているだけで
その時点でバカバカらしいんです
なんであるものはないと言うんですかね
嘘を言ったってもね どうったことはないんだよと
でも嘘をつくっていうことはあるでしょうに
真理語ってもどうったことはない
真理語るってことはあるでしょうに
だからあるところでお釈迦様言うんですよ
このあるものが堂々とないというのはね
あまりにもイカれてると私は思いますよと
よう咎めたところもあります
この場合も道徳倫理は成り立ちませんね
例えば虚無主義者はまあどうせ道徳も全部否定するでしょ
反宗教者たちは宗教の修行は全部否定するでしょ
だから無論者にも道徳はないんです
有論者にも道徳は成り立たない
人間が努力して成功するということは成り立たないんです
だから彼らが明確に真昼で暗いという人々なんです
なぜならば なんで真昼ですかというと
我々は努力することで成長するのは経験済みなんです
人間が進化したということを経験済みなんです
勉強すれば頭が良くなったということは経験済みでしょうに
仕事をすれば金が入ったということを経験済みでしょうに
金が入ったところで いいアパートに住めるようになりましたと
これ経験済みでしょうに
証拠済みなのに否定すると
これ真昼は暗いということなんです
だから有論者も無論者も
この真昼は暗いんだよという立場をとっているんです
いわゆる経験済みのことさえ否定しているんです
だから この両極端の人々には道徳整理することは不可能です
私は道徳 道徳というのは
人間が意志的に行う行為のことなんです
別にお説教のことじゃないんです
人間が自分の意思で行う行為のこと
だから勉強することも道徳なんです
仕事をすることも道徳なんです
なぜならば 仕事をして幸せになる
勉強して良い人間になる
だから結果に 行為に結果があるんです
それで行為に結果があるんだから
悪い結果になる行為を避けて
良い結果になる行為を選ぶ
小さい時は遊ぶことをやめて学校に行くことを選ぶ
ゲームセンターに行くことをやめて塾に行く
それ道徳判断でしょうに
お母さんにも何と言いますか
何と言って家出るんですかね
忘れちゃった 挨拶の言葉
行ってきます  あ 行ってきますと
学校から帰ってきて それからまたカバンを持って行ってきますと塾に行く
その子供には選択ありますよ
塾に行くか ゲームセンターに行くか
あるいは塾に行くか 川のそばで塾が終わるまで遊ぶかと
どちらでもできますよ
それで子供は道徳判断しますね
やっぱり悪いんだから塾に行きますと
そういうわけで 道徳っていうのは
人間が自分の意思で判断して
行為いくつかの中で一つを選ぶ
それが良い結果になる行為を選ばなくてはいけないんです
それがしっかり定めてないと
論理的に整理してないと困るんです
しかし 世の中はもう九十九パーセント有論者で
一パーセントぐらい無論者で
どちらでも道徳否定者なんです
この場合も道徳論にはなりたちません
苦しんでいる生命に救いはないんです
はい デジタル脳ということで
なんで私がこのデジタルという言葉を使ったかというと
これ有と無なんですよ
デジタル世界も同じでしょ
信号があるかないか だからコンピューターは一かゼロか
電気が電子があるかないかでしょ
コンピューターはあるで動いているんです
ないで機能停止するんです
我々にはこの その差で画像やらいろんなものを見るんです
だからコンピューター見てもあの一とゼロなのにゼロは認識しないんです
有で機能反応する 無でストップする
脳 脳も同じことなんです
本当はこの最近作ったコンピューターと珍しくなく
あの自然法則そのもの
同じデジタルなんです
小さい家父も我々の心もすべてデジタルなんです
だから小さい家父でできている脳もあるかないかということで動いているんです
だから整理整頓して学ぶと覚えやすいでしょ
頭もしっかりと論理的に整理すると
物事を理解しやすいでしょ
すべてデジタルなんです
ストップはありえないので
無の時勝手に有の世界を幻想する
これはちょっと時間伸ばしちゃうと
では 例えばコンピューターが一分間
信号を認識しないと我々は壊れたと思うんです
だって何も反応もないんだから
で 車のエンジンも動きっぱなしじゃないんです
本当は有で無で動く 止まる動く止まるでエンジンが動いてますけど
この止まるっていうことは一分二分になっちゃうと
まあ心配でたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
だからあまりにも早く動くんだから
これは気づかないんですね
そこで私たちの場合は
一時間 二時間 何もやることがない場合は
随分派手に妄想の世界に入っちゃうんです
幻想の世界に入るんです
しかし の心は価値観を持っているんです
これがまずいんですよ
それは感情ということです
で パソコンはデジタルですけど
感情は持ってないんです
ですね だから大人がアクセスするサイトに子供がアクセスしたっても
コンピューターは何のことなく全部見せるんです
あんた子供でしょ？いい加減にしろよっていうことを判断しません
で 私は逆に子供が見るページとか見るんだからね
決してコンピューターは怒りません
いい大人で何やってるのかと
いい加減にしろよとは言わないんです
ですから だから この物質の場合は
物質そのものが価値観を持ってないんです
心は価値観を持ってるんですね
だからそれは感情なんです
価値観というのは ですから
心はだらしない 曖昧の不安のものであり
癒すのがなく浮いている状態なんです
どんな人間の心もだらしないんです
一切で浮いてる状態なんです
性格は定めてないんです
曖昧中途半端なんです
心がうとむとずっと動いているんです
感情で だから価値観にして
あ これでこれは悪い これでこれが悪いとかね
ある時悪いと言ったものを後でまた良いとしたりする
良いとしたものを また後で悪いとしたりする
それで価値観割り込みますから
常に生命の精神状態は不安になるんです
はい これで仏教の話に入ります
有無の問題の解決 有は極論
無は極論 ではどうすればよろしいかと
有と無をます知るんです
心に刺激が触れる さあ
それなりの有があると知られる
しかし その情報は変わる
なくなる 心にデータが触れたら走るんですね
あ それなりの何かがあると知ってほしい
そうすると次にそのデータが変わるんですね
それでかつてあった 今ないという法則で申しるんです
お釈迦様は無を知る方法を教えているんです
かつてあった 今はない
これはパーリ語である論理文章がちょっと長いんだから
私はこう言ってもうすごく縮めたんです
X was in the past, but X is not present now という
X という現象はあったが今ない
これも引き算なんです
引き算でしか知られません
だからお釈迦様は堂々と引き算使ってるんです
人間が引き算しているくせに
引き算ではありませんと思ってるんです
お釈迦様は全部引き算で教えているんです
知られないものは引き算で言うんです
例えばよく知ってるで
貪瞋痴 次は不貪不瞋愚痴でしょ
物の見事な引き算でしょ
ますそうやって知ってほしいんですね
有と無を知る 有は簡単に知れます
知れます 音があるとしますね
あ 今音がある それで音が消えるでしょ
当然 あ 今音がないと どうやって音がないとわかる？かつてあったんだからなんです
かつてなかったならばわからないんです
だから音があって今ないという風に認識しなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると有も無も知られるように
どんどんどんどんなるんです
マイナス有は無です このこうやって読めるかどうかわかりません
これ書いてるのはマイナス有
数学で書いたんです マイナス有は無なんです
だから私はこの般若心経をからかって本を出しましたけど
あれは一番わかりやすい
俗っぽい判断反論ですけど
実際はこういうところなんです
相当な頭が悪いって私は言ってるのは
このブッダの有論無論中道論の立場からなんです
いい加減こうとこうと思うと言うなよと
全くその論理はないんです
だから話にならない本なんです
あの空論を整理したのは龍樹ですけど
龍樹は理論をもって空というんですね
その程度でもないんです
全くも小学生の作文です
マイナスウのブッダの言葉
ブッダがどのようにマイナスを整理するのかというと
イマスミンサティイダンホーティ
これがあるとき これがあります
イマスミンアサティイダンナホーティ
これがないとき これはない A
があるとき Bもありますと
AがないときBもないと
だからBがあることも B
がないこともそのように理解するんです
イマスウッパダイダンウッパッジャティ
これが生じるとき これは生じる
イマスニローダイダンニルッジャティ A
Aという現象が生じてくると B
という現象も生じるんだよと A
という現象が消えていくと B
という現象も消えていくんだよと
それで引き算なんです
マイナスウなんです 例えばね
わかりやすいといえば
お腹に食べ物はある場合は満腹でしょうね
はい 空腹感がある お腹に何もないというのはあるという意味なんで
お腹があって何もない
それで空腹感がある それでお腹に何か入れると
それで空腹感がない  そんなもんです
そんなに難しくはないんです
で 花が咲いているとミツバチが来ると
花がある時 ミツバチもいる
花がない時はミツバチがいない
それは調べたってもね
経験 ちょっと難しいんですね
だから花がない どんなところでもミツバチがいないんですね
ということになっちゃうんです
そうするとあまりも大きいんだから
小さなところで取るんです
花があるとき それは 1箇所だからね
花があるとき ミツバチがいる
そこで全体的に花がないときはミツバチがいない
だから世界中から花が消えちゃうと
ミツバチはみんな死んじゃいます
消えてしまいます これが滅するとき
これは滅する それはお釈迦様の法則なんですね
皆様方 それよく知っている
聞いたことがある これは因果法則の初式なんですね
ウート と言っても一時的で有にはならない
無と言っても一時的で無にはならないんです
だから有と言ったらあかんやと
これ一時的だから 無と言ってもあかんやと
一時的ですよと 因縁によって生じる
生じたものは因縁によってなくなる
これが真理なんです 有でも無でもないんです
有の極論も無の極論も超えて
ブッダは中正中正で真理を語るんです
それでブッダが中正 中正
中正 中正という言葉を導入するんです
これは真ん中という意味じゃないんです
本当のことを語るんです
あるでもないでもないんです
因縁によって一時的にある
一時的になる ない だからあってない
なくてある あってなくないという
生と滅す 生と滅すだと
それも原因 原因 原因やと
あるというためにも原因が必要
ないというためにも原因が必要ですと
現象をユニットで取るのではなく
因果のセットで取るんです
それで世界は有で取るか無で取るかなんです
ブッダがセットで取るんです
原因と結果 因果で取るんです
なぜ縁起かと 縁起だから現象を変えられる
変えられます 縁起だから
執着したり拒否したりする必要はないんです
縁起でしょうに すぐすぐ変わりますからね
執着する必要はないんです
煩悩を怒る必要もないんです
縁起がわかったらもう煩悩がないんです
財布に金があったって
まあこれはどうしても消えますよと
これ使うものやとそのままあったってもただの紙ですからね
だけどそこに執着ないんですね
人の意志 道徳 行為は結果を出すんです
因果法則だからこそ 人の意志があったらそれなりの結果が出てくる
行為に結果が出てくる
ですから道徳は成り立つんです
したがって道徳は成り立ちます
ちょっと太い文字で書きました
仏教では道徳は成り立ちます
解脱は可能です 仏教が唯一の宗教です
仏教は宗教ない宗教はないと私は言いますけど
逆に宗教はインチキであるならば
唯一の宗教は仏教なんです
どちらかならないとね
世界のインチキ宗教だとするならば
仏教は勘弁してくれと
我々は宗教ではありませんと
世界の宗教でどうしよう困った問題だと言ったら
いえ 大丈夫です 宗教はたった一つあるんだよと
これは仏教だよということなんです
極論から極道極道い 極道と呼ばないでください
この場合は極道ですね
生命は思考で判断して生きているんです
生命っていうのは思考で判断して生きているんです
思考は有無の極端の一つ
その枠に入ります したがって
我々の生き方も極道に極道になっているんです
人間の生き方は何であろうとも極道なんです
極端なんです だって有で考えて行動するか
無で考えて行動するかなんです
人は何か良いか何か悪いか明確には知らないんです
はっきりその判断ないんです
因果法則知らないでしょ
本当はそういう良い悪いって成り立たないんです
因果法則によっても 有か無で決めた極端的な生き方か
有と無の間で彷徨う半端な生き方になるんです
実際 我々の生き方を見ると
例えば断然的に宗教に入って
信仰で氷固まっている人々もいるし
断言的に宗教嫌いな人々もいるし
真ん中の変なやつらもいるんです
曖昧中途半端で好き勝手
まあ好きとも言え 嫌い嫌いとも言えないんですけど
まあそれぞれ宗教のいいところはあるんだけど
まあでもまあどちらでもいいところもあるんだけどとかね
どうにもならん曖昧な連中なんですね
結局は人間 その 3種類なんです
この極端か この極端か曖昧か
どちらかなんです はい
多数の道って何でしょうかね
多数は右の檻にいます
あの無は少数派ですよ
みんな右の世界なんです
感覚器官で刺激を受けることに徹しています
右の世界だから 刺激を受けて刺激を受けて刺激を受けてきているんです
刺激欲しい 刺激欲しいと
好む刺激も好まない刺激もあるから
当然好む刺激のみを期待し
探し求め努力するんです
そこで一般大衆は刺激が欲しいんですね
美しいものを見たいし
美しい音を聴きたいし
美味しいものを食べたいし
肉体には楽をさせたいし
良い刺激欲しいんです
悪い刺激は嫌なんです
世界では良い刺激 悪い刺激
両方あるんです それで良い刺激を避けて悪い刺激を避けて
良い刺激を得るために努力するんです
頑張ってるんです これは世間一般人の生き方なんです
快楽を求める道は世間の道なのです
世間が快楽を求める道を歩んでいるんです
しかし 動物さえも快楽の道なので
自慢にはなりませんよ
この人間が快楽の道を歩んでますけど
自慢にならないんです
なぜならば 動物さえも快楽の道なんです
ほとんどの生命は快楽の道なんです
まれ変人だけ 一部何人かが無の世界に入るんです
だから極論と言ってもバランスがないんです
例えば 1億人が人がいるとすると
3人ぐらいはもう無の世界で
残り全部有の世界なんです
極端ですけど 人間を 2つに分けて極端に言ってるわけじゃないんです
だからこの大衆の道 快楽主義は動物さえも
ミミズさえも アメーバさえも快楽主義なんです
だから人間に自慢できるところじゃないんです
この道では誰にも成長を期待できません
快楽主義で成長するならば
ミミズも成長するんです
成長しないでしょう 犬
猫 野生の鳥たちも成長するはずなんです
何の成長もないでしょう
ただ大きくなって生まれて
大きくなって もう餌を取って食べて
子孫作って死ぬ 次から次へも同じこと
人間も同じことをやっていて
何の成長もないんです
刺激は満足に達する前に消えるんです
ご飯は美味しいんだけど
美味しいということを満足する前にご飯が終わってるんです
お腹がいっぱいなんです
常に心は不満です ですから
いつでも心は不満なんです
だからみんな食べ過ぎになっちゃいます
だって美味しいでしょ？美味しいものを食べたらもうお腹がいっぱいになってるんですが
美味しいという刺激が足らないんです
刺激が十分受ける前にご飯が終わってるんです
だからもっと食べちゃうんです
だから私は痩せるためにスローモーションでご飯を食べなさいと言っているのはそういうわけなんです
スローモーションでゆっくり噛んでゆっくり味わって食べると
毎日食べるものの半分でお腹がいっぱいになるんです
あまりにも満足しちゃって
夜は食べる気にはならなくなっちゃうんです
これで痩せますよ さらに刺激を求めるという悪循環にはめます
それで刺激で満足しないでしょ
で さらに刺激を求めるんです
満足しないでしょ さらに求めるんです
それで悪循環が生まれてくるんです
すべてが衰えるので 感覚器官も衰える
それですべて衰れるんだけど
これは知らない みんな
どんなものにもエントロピーっていうことがあるんです
これ知らないんです だから目は衰えていくんですよ
だから まだ見足りてないのに
目が見えなくなっていくんです
まだ聞き足りてないのに
耳が遠くなっていくんです
満たさぬままで生命は死ぬんです
だからすごい渇愛だけ残して死ぬんです
快楽の道は渇愛が支配する
だから我々は渇愛の奴隷
渇愛はやれやれということを何でもやります
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどがついてくる
渇愛に争い 差別 競争 殺し合いなどで人生の大半を負うんです
人生の大半というのは
争いやら競争やら そういうものでしょう
24時間の中でたくさん時間をやっているのは
快楽の道はブッダの言葉ではヒーの癒し
願望品格はない ポートジャニク
多数の道 アナリよ 尊厳はない
あなたにとは不幸を司る道なんです
だから大衆多数の道 大衆の道はそんなもんなんです
快楽主義は はい 次に行きます
否定主義者の道 で これはもうわざと読みにくくしたんです
極論者である無にこだわる人は
当然快楽主義を否定するんです
この快楽主義を否定するんですよ
無論者は極論者 無の極論者は
ですから快楽主義を否定するんです
楽ではなく あえて苦を受けるんです
その人々は楽を受けるんじゃなくて
楽を受けるのは当たり前なんですけど
やめましょう やめましょう
苦しみましょう 苦しみましょうと苦しみを受けるんです
ですから 苦しんで読んでください
求めることは人が挑戦するべき道だと思う
苦を求めること 苦しみを求めることは
人が歩むべき道だと極論の無論者が思うんです
宗教の道 修行の道 幸福の道
目指すべき道とは苦行の道なのだと説く
苦行だとよ 苦行だよと
快楽行では何も得られませんよと
だったら苦行しましょうと
と苦行を説くんです この道
ブッダはドゥッカを苦しみアナリヨ
尊くない アナッタサンヒと不幸を司るのだと説かれています
はい これで極限極度の道 2つあります
快楽主義と苦行主義 快楽主義は嫌と思う人々は苦行を推薦するんです
だから人類がいつでもこの極端の道 2つで生きているんです
その他大勢の人々は快楽主義
一部の人々は苦行主義
こんなわけだ はい 読みやすくします
はい 大衆の考え えーと
右から読みます 大衆は快楽主義です
快楽で絶望感に陥ったら
修行の道に未練を感じる
自分は行いたくはないが
修行する人に魅力を感じることもある
修行に反対が 修行者が堕落していると批判することもあります
その全ての場合も 修行とは苦行に限ると思っているんです
それで俗世間にいる人々はね
時々修行がありがたいなと思ったりするんです
こんな朝から晩まで仕事するんじゃなくて
たまにお寺に入って修行したいんだと
あるいは絶望感に陥った時なんです
仕事うまくいかないわとかね
会社は赤字ばっかりになったりするとね
はぁ 道場に入りたいなとかね
どうったことないんです
あれは しかし その人々は苦行をすることが修行だと勘違いしています
時々宗教を批判する人がいるんですよ
宗教には興味ないんだと
しかし 現在の修行者たちがみんなだらしないんだと
贅沢三昧だと 何言ってるんですかね
自分が贅沢三昧は正しいと言っているのに
なんで修行者が贅沢三昧悪いんですかね
それでわかるでしょ 意味は
修行は苦行に限るという哲学なんです
俗世間では修行は苦行に限るとは定説です
苦行者は いわゆる無論者は修行は苦行であると教えているんです
道は苦行であるべきで教えているんです
快楽主義者も 修行たるものは苦行であると思っているんです
自分はやってないんです
快楽主義だから しかし
修行は苦行であると思っているのです
ということは 人間には道がわからないんです
快楽主義か苦行家なんです
はい ブッダはまあゆらゆらしているね
特修行っていうのは中道なんです
快楽業 苦行を超えた現実的な幸福の道なんです
ブッダは快楽業も捨てる
苦行も捨てる 別な道を発見するんです
はい この別な道の説明に入ります
はい まず正しいという言葉に仏教は引っかかっているんです
あの正しいというのはパーリ語でサンマと言うんですね
それは日本語訳すると正という訳しますけど
英語で言えばこれはパーフェクトという
パーフェクト パーフェクトという意味なんです
いわゆる完全 という形容詞は仏道に欠かせないんです
極論ではなくて 完全なんです
極端の両極も正しくないのです
極端の中 真ん中も中も従って正しくはないんです
だから半分快楽で半分苦行も完全に間違っているんです
快楽は間違っているならば
苦行が間違っているならば
半分の快楽も半分の苦行も半分半分で完璧に間違いなんです
だからブッダが語っている中道は真ん中道ではないんです
パーフェクトの道なんです
正道なんです だから正は正という正しいという字は
仏教には大変必要なんです
遊びじゃないんです ちょっとした文法的な飾りじゃないんです
なんとなくの形容詞ではないんです
もう大変です 命です 仏教の仏法の魂なんです
この初という字は どのような道を歩むべきかという正解があるはずです
一応 人間が何するべきかという正解があるはずなんです
必ず幸福という結果を出す
その道 超越性 中道は仏道なんです
この正解の道を仏教が語っているんです
それに中道とも言うんです
超越道と言っても正しいんです
本当は小道なんです 中道ではないんです
小道なんです 八正道でしょ
はい 小道のポイント 有と無で彷徨う人間の問題は
縁起が知らないことにあるんです
なんで有で無で彷徨っているかというと
縁起が知らないんですね
因縁によって有であって
因縁がなくなると無だよと
それ知らないんです あった
なくなった ただそれだけ
あ かわいそうやと 現象はあるでもなく
ないでもなく 因縁によって一時的に成り立つのです
はい これがポイントです
因縁によって一時的に成り立つ
あるでもない ないでもない
真ん中でもない あるでもない
ないでもない 有も両方でもない
有でもなく ないでもなく
両方でもないでもないんです
インド論理は 4択ですからね
イエス ノー イエス アンドノー
ニードイエス ノーノーという 4択なんです
このどちらでもないんです
因縁によって成り立つ
成り立つはあるでもないでもないでしょ
したがって執着に値しない
だからどんな現象にももう執着に値しない
ただ成り立つだけだから
一時的に これを発見するために正見正思惟が必要です
だから正見がね 正しい見解が必要なんです
このマインドコントロールしてどうにもならんですね
矛盾だらけでどうにもならん
しっかりした見解が必要なんです
しっかりした主義がしっかりではなくて
正思惟が必要なんです
正しい思考 道徳が成り立つんだから
仏教でね 頑張ったら結果が出ますからね
ですから 正語 正業 正命が必要なんです
正語っていうのは 語ることは正しいことを語る
行いは正しい行いをする
生計は正しい仕事で生計を立てる
それは道徳なんです 常識は有無の回転なので
常識を超えるための正精進と正念が必要です
ちょっと正念拝礼するの忘れちゃった
精進しなくちゃいけないんです
正精進 正解のために精進するんです
なぜかというと 我々この常識破らなくちゃいけないんですよ
これ頑張らないと だから常識破る方法は正念ですね
正しく観察する ありのままに
この 2つがどうしても必要なんです
それは修行のセクションです
前書いたのは道徳のセクションなんです
一番前の 2つは理解のセクションなんです
理解と道徳と修行 徐々に成長して超した境地に達するので
症状が必要です それで理解して納得して落ち着くんです
ごまかしで落ち着くではないんです
はい 神がいるんだと 永遠な地獄天国あるんだと言ったら落ち着くでしょ
あんなのはインチキ 間違い
マインドコントロール
騙し この場合 そうじゃなくて
本物の落ち着きが生まれてくるんです
それで八正道です 安らぎです
清浄で解脱悟りを意味しています
だから理解を正して 正しい道徳を歩んで
正しい修行をして 正しい境地に達するんです
これがお釈迦様八正道だと
もうすごい教えなんです
これが神 神 人間 悪魔 鬼
誰にも発見もできなかったと
言えることもできないんだと
これこそ生命の中で唯一の偉大な発見であると言われているんです
極端を捨てた完全な道という意味で
仏教も仏道も常に小なのです
完全という言葉 「しょう」という文字がものすごい必要なんです
ですから ちょっとそこっぽい話に入ります
灰色の世界では困ります
子供は はい これで言いたかったのは
極論が嫌だったら真ん中に立つでしょ
あれダメなんです 極論間違いだったら真ん中もダメなんです
我々一般人がこの灰色の世界にいるんです
とんでもないんです 子供は遊ぶべきか
いえ 遊ぶべきか 学ぶべきか
普通の答え 適当に遊んでよく学ぶべきっていうことでしょう
しかし この適当ってどれぐらいですかね
どれぐらいのことわかってないでしょ
曖昧でしょ 欲とはどれぐらいのことですかね
適当に遊んでよく学ぶと
この適当ってどれぐらい？よく学ぶってどれぐらい？わからないでしょ？いい加減なことを灰色のとこ言ってるだけ
遊んではダメ ダメとも言いませんね
勉強ばっか これもばっかし
じゃあ真ん中取るぞと
冗談じゃないんです 正しくないんで
その答えは灰色で 正解は
子供は日々良い方向へ成長するように努むべきです
なんです 努むべきです
勉強とかなんだらかんだら話じゃないんです
遊ぶとかなんだらかんだらではないんです
日々良くなるように成長する
それに努めるんです これが正解です
完璧な答えなんです もし遊ぶことでも学ぶならばどうする？もし学ぶことが遊びになったらどうする
？例えばもう適当に遊んでてよく学んでくださいという子供がいて
その子は勉強が好きで楽しいんですね
そうすると遊ばないでしょ
あの正解から見ると間違ってますね
あの子は だって遊んでないんだから
仏道は上手じゃないんです
その子は成長するのかしないのか
良くなっていくのかいないのか
それだけなんです 人生には正解はあるが
それを発見できないのは残念です
いつでも我々には正解があるんです
朝から晩まで生きている時はいつでも正解あるんですけど
これ発見できないんです
いつでも中途半端で曖昧で
これが残念ですけど これが私の読めなくなっちゃった
これ選択の渦巻き 渦巻きにもう隠れもう隠れて読めなくなりました
我々は判断に困る 悩む
いつでも選択には 選択はたくさんあります
たくさんです 悪い場合でも良い場合でも
いくつかの選択の中で悩む
一つを選んでしまっても
別なものを選んだ方が良かったのではないか
かとまた悩む あまり内容は難しくないんです
毎日のことだからね この竜巻から脱出する方法はあるのでしょうか？と
これ 選択の問題ですよね
選択はたくさんあるんですよ
どちらにしよう どちらにしようかと悩むんです
例えば 悪いことが回ってくるときでも
いくつか回ってくるんです
良いことが回ってくるとも
いくつか回ってくるんですね
だからどちらにしようかと悩むんですね
それで まあどうしてもないんだから
一つを選ぶでしょ 選んでも
まさかこれじゃなくて
あれやった方がよかったんじゃないな
ないんですけど また悩むんです
そういうわけで 人間というのは
この選択判断という渦巻きでものすごく悩まされているんです
はい 選択の渦巻き あります
解決する方法は 選択はたくさんということは
一つも正解ではないんです
正解っていうのはいつでも一つですよ
だから 私には選択 4つがありますよって言ったら
4つが正解ではないんです
まるっきりダメとは言いませんだけど
正解ではないんです 良いところも悪いところも混ぜているんです
だから選択は 4つある
例えば もう高校生は大学 4つ浮かんだとする
受かったとする 一つ選ばなくちゃいけないでしょう
必ず悩むんです あの大学はこれ
これが良くて これこれはない
この大学はこれあるんだけど
あれあれがないと この大学はこれこれがあるんだけど
もう結構いいところなんですけど
遠いとか この大学はもうこれこれがあって
これこれがないとかね
だから点数入れたっても
この大学は 60点 このこの大学も 60点な
このそれも 60点 このこれも 60点
じゃあやれやれと だから高校生が自分受かった大学 4つに点数を入れてみても
結局同じ点数になっちゃうんです
選べないんですね ということは
どんな選択にも良いところがあって
悪いところもある どちらもどちらを選んでも大したことになりません
だから答え一 どちら選んだっていいよと
大学 4つの名前を紙に書いて
こう巻いて で お父さんにこれを巻いて回ってくださいと
で 一つ選ぶ はい この大学にしました
いいんです それで どうってことないんです
に できるならブッダに説かれる道を選ぶ
これは正道なんですね
だから大学 4つ受かった子供も
ブッダに聞けば ブッダが君はね
能力を開発して立派な人格者になれと言うんです
では 立派な人格者になる場合は
どんな大学が一番いいのかと決めれば
簡単です だから 人格で判断すれば
どんな仕事 ミスはあります
どんな仕事が良いのかと
自分の人格向上にどんな仕事がいくらか影響を与えるのかと調べて
それに入るんです それが正解なんです
選び方 俗世間では 何を選んでも成長も長所も短所もあることを覚悟する
この世の中で どんなものにも短所
長所があるということを覚悟してください
結婚したってもね 相手が一番優しい人か
いい加減短所も長所もあります
捨てた選択を完全に忘れるんです
結婚しましょうと男３人に頼まれてあっても
結婚するは一人選ぶでしょうね
あの二人はきれいさっぱり忘れなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの人も選んだ方がよかったんじゃないかなとかね
まあ念のために電話したりとか
コミュニケーションを取っておこうとかね
これではダメなんですよ
一つ選んだら 他の選択は全部チャラ
もう皆無なんです そうしなきゃダメの
でなきゃ ずっと人生は中途半端で終わっちゃうんです
選択の短所により生じる不幸に対して
別な道を選んで対応するんです
一応一人の男を選んだんだけど
この選んだ男にも短所があるんだからね
この短所によって自分がいろいろ苦労したり
悩んだりするでしょうね
その悩み解決にもう一つ別な
こと選んでおくんです
まあ例えばね まあ自分もちょこちょこっとちょっとした仕事を見つけるとかね
いろいろあるでしょう
まあ仏教を学ぶことは一番いいんですけど
もう旦那の面倒を見てあげて
残る時間で自分が仏教を学ぶと
そうすると あの旦那の短所から出てくる苦しみがこれでチャラになっちゃうんですね
そういう風な吐け口というかね
例えば東大を選んだら
もう閉鎖社会で頑固わがままな人々は暗い環境で勉強はする
しかし 人間としてはちょっとダメになっちゃうんですね
それだったら 大学でピシピシと勉強しながら
自分今まで付き合ってきた友達との友達関係をしっかり保つと
いうことで 人間関係は別な世界で解決すればいいんです
そういう風に この短所の悪い結果を和らげていくんです
道徳の場合は選択ありません
だからといって道徳の場合は選択ないんです
仏教の仏教の道徳 それはもう断然的決まりなんです
もうどうしようもないんです
しかし お釈迦様がよろしければ守ってくださいと言いますけど
それは選択あるわけじゃないんです
ただ 人間の尊厳を守っているだけ
道徳は自由意志で守らなきゃ道徳にならないんだからね
だからお釈迦様は正道で語る
よろしければ守るのがよいと
守りなさいというと正道でなくなっちゃうんです
だからで道徳には選択ないんです
全体的に人生を八正道のプログラムで生かす
一番正しい答えは 我々生まれてから死ぬまで何やってもいいんだけど
八正道の枠でやればどうですか
八正道は人生全体なんです
そうすると ブッダに説かれた発見した正解の道を歩むことになるんです
悩む必要ないんです いきなり八正道で決める
その決めた時点から人生は好転していくんです
何の苦しみもなく 何の悩むこともなく
何の不幸もなく ものの見事に成長します
だから選択に悩む必要はないんです
一応八正道でやればよろしい
それで話が終わりです
やっと はい そういうわけで
この中道って大変難しいでしょう
で 極端の道を避けて中道を選ぶというね
正道を選ぶんですね これ
かなり高度な仏教の話になります
まあ申し訳ないんですけど
まあいくらか理解できてならばありがたいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
あの 今日ちょっと九時までということでしたので
少し 次お話がちょっと取れませんが
皆さんと最後に廻向の文で終了したいと思います
それでは回向して参ります
廻向の文 仏法僧の三宝に大拝敬し
帰依の上に 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 父母 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得ますように
サッティーテーオーイワッジャンツーサンベローゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーバワットアンテラーヨーサケーデーガーユコーバワ
バワトゥサッバマンガランラッカンツサンバデーヴァタサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナ
サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥテー
アーユラーローキサンパッティサンガサンパッティメーワチャ アトー ニッバーナサンパッティ ミナテー サミッジャトゥ
はい ではありがとうございます